[Musique]
le paysage ou regarder partout c'est
magnifique on respire la fureur les gens
fondation il ya beaucoup de services au
style de lois vraiment
[Applaudissements]
j'avais un mode de vie qui était très
très très urbain donc on avait envie de
changer puis on a changé ici à la
campagne un autre petit matin de routine
pour les anciens montréalais véronique
loubier patrice francoeur et leurs deux
enfants damien il y en a cela fait neuf
ans qu'ils ont déménagé à sainte
brigitte de laval
à une demi heure de route au nord de
québec comme jeune couple dans la fin
trentaine ils suivent la campagne
électorale un peu en dilettante et on a
toujours des présences et les mêmes
promesses qui sont remis à lui être
qu'on innove
est-ce qu'on estructura quand on fait
des réels changements
je me questionne beaucoup car jusqu'ici
tout ce qu'ils entendent ne correspond
pas à leurs attentes
c'est un brigitte de laval a beau avoir
l'air d'un havre de paix où il fait bon
vivre entre rivière et montagne les
défis sont énormes
d'ailleurs chaque matin quand elle
arrive sur son lieu de travail
véronique fait face à la réalité on a
une belle salle pour un médecin mais ya
pas de médecin effectivement donc on
travaille pas depuis plus de trois ans a
offert deux agents vie qu'on est ouvert
et les directrices de la coop de santé
de solidarité de la ville un centre de
soins où une infirmière accueille aussi
bien les poupons que les personnes âgées
mais les soins prodigués sont plutôt
élémentaire la clinique refuse chaque
jour des patients quand le service
demandé dépasse celui des infirmières à
sainte brigitte de laval
il n'y a plus de médecin depuis 14 ans
pourtant ce ne sont pas les jeunes
docteurs qui sortent de l'université qui
manque et qui voudraient pouvoir
pratiquer ici
mais la façon qu on répartit les
effectifs médicaux sur la province de
québec la façon que les territoires sont
divisés également davantage place un
projet de nous pénalise comme on fait
partie de la grande région de la
capitale nationale qui selon les règles
semblent dire que le nombre de médecins
et un nouveau pacte rural
de la relève sont suffisants sur le
territoire pour les soins il faut faire
de 30 à 40 minutes de route pour trouver
une clinique sans rendez-vous où l'on
n'accepte plus de nouveaux patients
depuis belle lurette
bref c'est mme brigitte et ses 7500
résidents est victime de sa popularité
qui n'est pas pour ainsi dire reconnus
par le gouvernement au cours des dix
dernières années la population a presque
doublé au niveau de la ville donc c'est
sûr que pour la ville il y aurait
énormément de défis
[Musique]
sainte brigitte est la deuxième plus
jeune villes du québec
moyenne d'âge ici un peu moins de 34 ans
des enfants il y en a partout les écoles
ça déborde chez nous bien qu'on a une
nouvelle école y aura environ 3 1 on est
déjà à réfléchir à savoir qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
cette année il y a neuf classes de
maternelle il ya quelques années il y
avait une liste d'attentes de plus de
500 ans pour les garderies mari michel
parent a ouvert ce service privé pour
améliorer l'offre
il ya quand même un phénomène assez les
gens aiment bien venir s'installer mais
qui est aussi il ya beaucoup de
migration car il ya déjà qui vient
s'implanter à des nouveaux mais ça se
promène il ya quand même le déplacement
et ce qui resterait plus longtemps s'ils
avaient plus de services par exemple un
médecin ou de des choses comme ça je
pense que de poser la question frédéric
cv répand il comme un défi n'attend pas
l'autre
la ville ne dispose que d'une seule
route pour sortir en direction de québec
s'ils avaient une bande à 101 feu outre
sa place à un accident qui paralyse la
route principale on est coincés à la
maison donc sans services médicaux ça ça
pose problème
on attend en moyenne 50 minutes en blanc
sur le territoire pour a été desservi
aussi
seule solution demander une étude de cas
pour démontrer que le besoin d'un
médecin est criant ce qui n'a jamais été
fait ici à cause de toutes ces
incertitudes la clinique a déjà failli
fermer ses portes
mais pour l'instant on parvient tout
juste à maintenir la tête hors de l'eau
certes brigitte de laval et dans la
circonscription de montmorency qui a
mangé un peu à tous les râteliers
politique du pq de la caq ou encore des
libéraux dernièrement les lavallois sont
donc très convoité d'ailleurs depuis le
début de la campagne électorale les
candidats se succèdent dans le bureau de
la côte de véronique loubier cet après
midi c'est au tour du candidat caquistes
d'écouter les doléances mais l'action
concrète suivra-t-elle vous avez terminé
votre magasinage politique vous avez
rencontré les quatre parties c'est quoi
votre sentiment maintenant c'est quoi la
prochaine étape c'est impossible qu'il
n'est pas une solution adaptée pour
notre communauté pour notre centre de
santé je ne crois pas c'est une question
de volonté aussi une question de
s'allier de se mobiliser de dire ok mais
pas assez c'est assez
on agit on avance en un projet portant
en tout cas dès le 2 octobre élire à
frapper davantage à la porte du député
qui sera élu éternel optimiste elle
reste cependant lucide
puisque rien n'a vraiment changé depuis
les 14 dernières années
[Musique]